hello there today we're looking at
resolution robust large mask in painting
with fourier convolutions also called
lama by the samsung ai center samsung
research epfl and the skolkovo institute
of science and technology this is a
special paper review because i'm only
going to introduce the paper briefly
maybe 15-20 minutes or so and then we're
going to talk to the first author of the
paper and go a lot more in depth so if
you like if you like conversations with
first authors and the ability for me to
ask dumb questions to them then stay
tuned for that it's going to be in the
second half of the video for the first
half though i first want to demonstrate
to you what this model can do hey there
this video is sponsored by clear ml
clearml is an ml ops stack that is fully
open source it can do experiment
tracking orchestration deployment model
and features stores and much more the
self-hosted tier is a first-class
citizen in clear ml as i said it's fully
open source you can look at it you can
audit it you can extend it you can run
it on your servers and if you ever come
to the point where you need the extra
features you can totally upgrade any
time they'll gladly take your money they
have a free tier in the cloud which gets
you going pretty far now we talked about
experiment tracking last time clearml
with two lines of code will track any
experiment that you do track the metrics
the outputs the environments the
dependencies and make everything super
duper reproducible but this time i want
to talk about a second part which is the
orchestration engine so the
orchestration engine is responsible for
packaging up your experiments including
all dependencies and then distributing
them on your hardware so that means you
can simply submit an experiment to a
particular queue and clearml takes care
of running this wherever it's needed so
this is super cool because it means i
can get going on my laptop run a few
experiments there and as soon as i'm
ready boom i ship it to the cloud so
here's an example look at this
experiment that has already been run i
got some output but now i would like to
do something different with it so i
click here i say clone i give it a
meaningful name like
two
and now i've cloned this experiment and
this is kind of a draft experiment right
now it has no results yet but what i can
do i can go into my configuration into
my hyper parameters and i can change
around the hyper parameters so i wasn't
really happy with the last experiment i
feel a bigger batch size might be needed
so from 128 let's go to
129. now i'm pretty sure that's gonna
make all the difference right here so i
save and then i simply click on enqueue
i submit it
and now clearml simply takes care of
running that experiment for me as you
might guess you can have different cues
some for gpu loads some for long running
tasks some high priority as you're used
to from any scheduler this can also be
used in an automated fashion meaning
that you can use this for automated
hyper parameter search and you can even
do things such as scheduled or triggered
tasks for example if you want to trigger
a training run every day on new incoming
data that's totally doable now
orchestration is just one part of clear
ml i've shown you experiment tracking
last time and there are many more
features to their product if this sounds
interesting to you if you're an open
source fan go check them out and thanks
so much to clearml for sponsoring this
video let's get into it
you can already see it a little bit in
figure 1 right here the model is able to
take a picture you draw a mask on it so
this is the blue area right here and the
model would auto complete the picture so
the model doesn't see the mask the model
simply sees what is unmasked then the
model is asked to complete that missing
area as you can see it fills that area
in you know very very cleanly and
especially if you look right here this
irregular structure of these door holes
or whatever that is is preserved even
across very large areas this is very
very cool this is very difficult to do
with these in painting systems in fact
there is a project website right here
all the code is available
they give this in a little bit more of
an animated flare so you can really see
the effect that these models are having
and it's pretty pretty cool especially
take a look at these repeated structures
that are often in the pictures so these
meshes or the lines right here these
tend to be extreme these tend to be
especially difficult for in painting
models because in painting models are
usually built on convolutional neural
networks and convolutions uh notably
take into account very local context
whereas for these patterns you need to
take into account kind of a global
context that's exactly going to be the
uh the message right here
there is an app there are actually a
bunch of apps based on this model this
is a third-party app so this is not
by the author but it is an app built
from these models there are also as i
said code is available there's like a
hugging face space there is a collab by
the author but this particular app let's
just take a picture right here it works
best on natural images of course but
we'll we'll just take the channel logo
right here and we'll say we want to
erase the pi sign right here look how
cool that works what about the paw
oh okay that that is that is
kind of disturbing how about the nose
no
no no i don't like that
um
but it should be able to yeah see so it
kind of completes uh lines if you cross
them out
so this should complete the table but
remove the leg you can see it's fairly
robust even to you sort of miss
specifying a bunch of things so here i
draw over the headline if you saw that
and it remained
the head headline remains so i removed
this part but i crossed into here a bit
you can see the line kinda remains now
it's got a bit of hair uh yes kill it
with fire in any case this is available
for you to use if you have more sensible
pictures i'm sure that that will work a
little bit better maybe
there are also different versions of the
model so keep that in mind and they
works also on different resolutions
that's why it's called resolution robust
large mask in painting which is also
very cool so what is the core idea of
this paper the core idea is going to be
these fourier convolutions right here
and these fourier convolutions are going
to be enabling the model to take into
account global context from the very
beginning what is the problem with a
convolutional neural network the problem
usually is that in a convolution if i
have a picture
a convolution on a particular point will
take into account its local neighborhood
right and then i sort of slide this over
the image right here and that will give
me my representation in the next layer
maybe that's going to be even of the
same size so for a given point right
here i will have a receptive field of
the point in the original image plus
some neighborhood usually we work with
three by three convolutions so all i'm
going to do really is i'm going to look
one pixel to the top and one pixel to
the bottom one pixel to the left and one
pixel to the right and that's about it
i'm not going to do any more looking
around
so how does a convolutional neural
network integrate information across the
whole image and the answer to that is by
going for multiple layers so if i simply
represent the picture as a set of pixels
in one dimension imagine that the one
dimension here is is the picture and i'm
gonna need a bit more space for that
so as you can see in the first layer um
from the first to the second layer
let's say we look at this particular
point right here it's going to be have a
receptive field of three so it's going
to look at these
pictures sorry at these pixels right
here
in the next layer
if you can see that the same location is
also having a receptive field of 3 right
here however
since for example this
particular pixel right here also had a
receptive field of three
and this particular one also as you can
see in from layer two on their total
receptive field of that so that all the
information in flow is going to be from
a receptive field of five therefore the
more layers we have the more of
information the more spatial information
can be included for a given particular
location in the output but as i said
that takes a lot of layers that takes
depth and especially for these
in-painting applications what you want
is kind of global information these
masks right here like these masks
they're pretty big
for an in-painting application so
they're pretty pretty wide and
if you can imagine a convolutional layer
that looks at a three by three pixel
neighborhood that might be something
right here
you know so you're gonna have a whole
lot of convolutional kernels that just
see the masked pixels they see nothing
of the outside they simply see a bunch
of masked pixels for a whole bunch of
layers right layer two layer three until
like layer four there's like there's
nothing no information at all at this
position about the outside world about
the world beyond the mask and even then
it's only like this area we need to go
many more layers before we get access to
information that is way outside of here
and at that point it
may already be too late so the fourier
convolutions they solve that they have
the ability at every single layer to
look at a global context and how are
they doing this
it's not super expensive in fact they're
doing this by using of course fourier
transformations a fourier transformation
will map a signal to its corresponding
frequency domain signal it is
essentially a different way of of
representing a signal so if you have a
signal let's say uh
like a pure sine wave you do a fourier
transformation of that entire thing you
can represent that as the components in
the fourier spectrum and that would
simply have like one component at the
particular frequency at which this sine
wave at which this sine wave is
operating that's the that's not the
frequency that's like one over the
frequency right here but in a more in a
more general sense a fourier transform
will decouple the spatial
resolution and give it a transform it
into frequency resolution so if you have
a fourier spectrum maybe you have a very
complicated signal right here
a complicated signal that will give you
also a complicated fourier spectrum like
you have a lot of this you have like
negative this frequency a lot of this
frequency not too much of this frequency
and so on if you do a convolution in
this domain
you simply convolve across neighbors of
the signal however if you do a
convolution in fourier domain you can
see you convolve across frequencies you
you convolve across neighboring
frequencies which means that these three
things
represent three particular sine waves
frequencies maybe the lowest one is like
a super long sine wave the second one is
like a bit of a faster sine wave the
third one is even faster sine wave but
what is important is that every single
component in the fourier spectrum
represents information about the
entirety of the signal and that is
exactly what we want whereas the regular
convolution is localized in
in pixel space the fourier convolution
is going to be localized in frequency
space but global in pixel space
that is very cool and of course 48
transforms are also one of the things
that are extremely fast it's essentially
a linear algebra operation and there are
very fast implementations of discrete
fourier transforms called fast fourier
transforms and that's exactly what they
do right here the whole architecture is
going to look like this
there is going to be the image the input
image x there's going to be a mask
during training that is produced by a
mask generation algorithm x is then
masked out and the model is tasked to
predict the missing pixels that are
hidden by the mask as i said the model
has no access to what's below the mask i
guess that would be kind of pointless
right yeah so
what we do first but also this is a
fully convolutional architecture that
makes it able to essentially transfer to
different resolutions which is another
advantage here being a fully
convolutional so what we do is first we
downscale a little bit as far as i can
tell these images are something like 256
by 256 during training or it works on
crops of 256 by 256 somewhere in that
range but the cool thing is it can
generalize to
high definition images like uh 1920 by
1080 or something like this the same
network so the train the network that's
trained on this low low quote-unquote
low resolution can generate can
generalize to very very high resolution
and it won't lose performance but we'll
see that in the experiment so first
there's down sampling and then the model
is just this it's just nine
layers um they also have a variant with
18 layers but the base model is nine
layers of this fast fourier convolution
residual block as you can see it has a
residual connection right here like a
normal resnet whereas a normal resnet
would have two convolutional layers
right here we opt for these fast fourier
convolutional layers
now they look a bit complicated but
essentially what we do is we carry two
different signals across the entire
network one signal contains local
localized information so one signal is
going to operate in the original domain
of pixel space and and has all that
those properties so it looks at its
neighbors and so on and one a signal is
going to operate in in more of the
global domain and then in each layer
those two strands of information get to
exchange information with each other so
the whole signal is represented as this
block here with the two components but
it's essentially just we have like two
strands of signal and then every now and
then they get to in exchange a bit of
information right one is the local the
local branch and one is the global
branch of information so what do we do
with the local branch we have a
different operations right here so we
have a little conv layer that is in
pixel space actually we have two of them
right two conv layers so we pass this
the local signal this is really just if
you just consider this
path right here through this one then
ignore ignore this here if you just go
here this is just like a normal convnet
right this path here gets information
from this side here
it receives it and then there is an
addition so what is that that is simply
this global signal the global signal
also doing a localized convolution in
pixel space so far there is nothing
special if we were to just do this this
would be it would be pointless to have
two strands of information right but the
important thing is that the global
strand comes to be in a very special way
so for that we have to look what
information arrives at the global branch
right here because that's the
information that's going to be passed in
here for the next layer for that we see
from the local branch there's a three by
three convolution going out over here so
let me draw that in greenish over here
and that is going to be mixed with this
global strand of information and the
global strand of information is going
through this spectral transform block
the specular transform block is
essentially pretty easy there is a
there's a batch norm sorry a convolution
batch norm relu block this is a one by
one convolution this is simply simply a
linear operator pixel wise essentially
and there's a batch norm there's a relu
for the non-linearity and then what we
do is we do a fast fourier transform in
2d and at the end of the block we're
going to invert that so
fast fourier transform to operate in
fourier space and then invert the fast
fourier transform at the end and inside
of it we're going to do a convolution
batch norm relu block right here so the
convolution again that's a one by one
convolution i believe followed by batch
number by relu so actually even forget
what i said about
localized convolutions right here if
they just do one by one convolutions
they really operate just on the
individual elements of the spectrum
by itself not even they don't even
consider localized sorry neighborhoods
of frequencies they just operate on the
individual frequencies
one by one which is is an option like
one by one convolutions are are a thing
so you know pretty cool this by itself
also has a residual connection right
here i'm gonna guess to make signal flow
better or more more stable or some
something like this the observant people
might object and say hey this thing
right here actually outputs complex
numbers so this is in the space of
complex numbers so you'll get vectors
with entries like a plus
plus ib
but what we do is simply we take those
and we stack them so we just make like
vectors out of them a and b so if there
is a bunch of numbers it will just be
like a1 b1
a1 b1 b1 a2 b2 and so on and we just
consider this to be a real vector of
double dimensionality or a real 2d
signal of double the dimensionality
as before and uh that
is how we do it i mean it's not it's not
entirely correct right but the model in
this way has access to all the relevant
information it can do what it wants with
it
uh yeah it can it can learn that half of
the dimensions correspond to two phases
uh or
or whatever whatever the complex part of
this is um it's been a while since since
been a while
since fourier transforms okay so these
are the exactly so here that's done we
have
sorry
go back up here to start it there is
first a real fft as you can see that
gets you to complex space then there is
complex to real in which we transform
the
c channels into two c channels but now
we're in the real numbers
then there is this relu batch norm conv
which retains the signal and there is
real to complex where we go back into
complex space so from reals 2d to c
channels in two complex just c channels
and then we reverse the fourier
transform
and that is a fourier convolution
as they define it
if we integrate
no that is the spectral transform block
right here the fourier transform the
fourier convolution is this entire
construct right here as you can see the
spectral transform information then
flows in here is combined with some
local information that really should be
green
and that then goes into this global
output and obviously will become the
global input to the next layer so that
is how they fuse localized information
with global information in every single
layer and that turns out to be pretty
pretty powerful they do have other
improvements right here and it's it's
crazy to see that just how much
engineering and how many tricks go into
these models to really get them to work
so they also stress that loss function
is a really really important topic right
here because you can't simply
reconstruct the original image right
here if you simply re tell the model to
reconstruct
the original image from here it's going
to be bad because if your mask is pretty
big pretty wide there can be many
possible fillings of the mask that makes
sense and since there are many possible
ones if you don't account if you don't
reward the model for getting one of the
possible ones without punishing it that
it didn't get all the other ones the
model is going to be very confused and
is simply going to output the average of
all the possible ones which we don't
want we want one of the possible ones
so
what we do is we apply a perceptive loss
they call that a perceptive loss and
they explain that over here what you do
is you feed uh the image the original
image this is uh the the real one
and the fake one and you can already see
there's going to be like a discriminator
later right
but you feed them both through a
pre-trained neural network
and then you compare at intermediate
points or even like at the last latent
layer you compare
the two feature maps so depending on how
this network is trained if that outputs
very perceptually salient features
you'll get like
a nice loss that doesn't punish you for
getting any pixels wrong but it
encourages you to get something that is
perceptually similar to what was there
in the original image they also stress
that it's really important on how you
train this network right here
they suggest to make this network also
include global context using either also
fourier convolutions or dilated
convolutions and here you can see that's
essentially the formula that means we
take the features from the original
image and the features from the fake
image and we calculate their distance
and that's going to be the high
receptive field perceptual loss
this is not the only thing they do they
also have as you can see an adversarial
loss there is also a regularizer on the
gradients
so yeah the final loss you're going to
end up with is like a mix of all of
these different losses there is also a
discriminator based perceptual loss and
this part right here is by itself again
a conjunction of two losses so rest
assured there's the loss architecture
right here is very very intricate and
i'm going to guess it's taken a lot of
experimentation not only by this paper
but by the whole field here to really
come up with with nice losses that make
your outputs nice obviously there's
going to be a bunch of hyper parameters
here to tune which is always fun but
they've they seem to have done a pretty
pretty good job
the last thing they stress which is
important is how you generate masks
during training so during training you
you can't just you know take your finger
and draw on pictures like i did you have
to have some heuristic way of generating
masks and uh i'm not gonna go into the
detail of how they do it you can see
here compared to this is one of the one
of the base lines and this is one of
their heuristics they they have a mix of
these large masks and the box masks so
sorry both are large but one is called
wide masks which are kind of polygons
that they round off the corners i think
and uh box masks which are sort of
heuristically generated boxes right here
or stacks of these boxes and that's and
they mix those two together in order to
get the final masking for their images
you can see these are fairly large like
this one here covers more than more than
half the image so these are challenging
challenging tasks but it is through
training with such large masks that you
get the models to really learn to fill
in it consistently so what you can see
is that in their results and we're not
going to go into all the ta like they
have a lot of tables a lot of ablations
but red essentially means that it's
worse than their model you can see
almost all of the table is red except
some models in some of the benchmarks
for example in the narrow masks you will
find situations where other models might
outperform their model but as soon as
you go to like wide masks it is no
longer
it's no longer really a competition at
all
yeah so
their model seems to be really good
those white masks they do a lot of
ablations where they switch out
different for example different
convolutions right here they show what
if we switch the fourier fire dilated
convolution which is also a way to
increase the receptive field rapidly or
by regular convolution and again while
there might be some improvements
sometimes on narrow masks as soon as you
go to wide masks the other models
degrade pretty quickly the dilated
convolution actually holds up fairly
well right here but one disadvantage of
that is that it's very hard to go to
higher resolutions because the higher
resolution you go the dilated
convolutions their receptive fields will
also shrink while the fourier
convolution's receptive fields will
always remain essentially global
so here we have some comparison to
baselines you can see of course they
chose these pictures well with kind of
the regular structure in the background
but check this out like this is even
this is even their model
but with regular convolutions and even
if they go deeper it doesn't really help
but like this this is just insane right
i i get it they picked this picture but
it is like is really good um you can
also see this building how it's
completed over here with different
methods and then with their method
and the mask was you know fairly fairly
big as you can see
also on the bottom this the mask is huge
yeah here they show what happens if you
go to higher resolution so on this
rather simpler problem you can see that
a lot of the models do well in the top
row if you just have the uh
kind of a lower resolution but if you go
to really high resolution a lot of the
models struggle while the
llama model here still does a big
a good job and their larger model
uh seems to be
even better
yeah again lots of ablations but i'm
gonna stop uh right here and we'll go
over to uh chatting with the first
author about this so i'll see you in a
bit hello everyone i'm here with uh
roman siveroff and elizabeth logachova
the authors of the llama paper and lama
system as well i guess i think this is
as much a paper as it is an engineering
effort and just because looking at the
paper it already dawns on just how many
things are important in this system and
then trying this out myself it really
works like it's snappy it's really cool
and the results are pretty great i have
to say for a for a learned system so
first like welcome both of you and and
big props on big props on this system is
very cool
so you've seen you've seen my video what
did strike you uh where where did i get
it wrong yeah uh first of all i think
that
you did a great job in uh describing the
overall paper and
i have almost
uh
no
you know i have almost nothing to
no complaints yeah no complaints
regarding that
and
maybe one point regarding the overall uh
overall point of the paper and yeah it
as it's seen from the title uh fourier
convolution might be stand out a little
bit more than other components but the
actually the paper is about that all
three components like like we generate
data and how we process uh images with a
neural network and how we uh optimize
this uh how what losses do we choose all
these three components are important and
yes sometimes they can be relatively
easily tuned from existing methods uh
and
allow to such easy tuning can help to
significantly improve the results so
that's that's what's the uh overall
point of the paper yeah i had this i had
the feeling to you again and again
stress that a lot of these things are
important especially the the three main
components and you did a lot of
ablations to also show that all of these
are important that's why i find it so
impressive right because people usually
just put which one did you start with
first did you first have the idea of the
fourier convolutions is was that the
motivation yeah now initially we started
when we when we started overall project
on the in painting we just started with
a
classic pix2pix so just
git clone and predict
an existing uh code base from fix to fix
and then we try to
step iteratively identify the most uh
weak points and try to understand uh
what is the reason behind that weakness
and
at some stage we understood that uh most
architectures we tried really lots of
different architectures and we tried uh
existing blocks from other in painting
papers and
we found that almost none of them can
handle repetitive patterns uh well and
yes we started
when we think about repetitions the one
of the most obvious thing that came in
mind is fourier transform because it is
very natural uh thing to
handle periodic signals and
first we started uh
composing a layer on our own and then we
just googled and found that ffc which
was uh proposed for recognition tasks
and we
thought that it is a great thing to
start with and took it and modified it
and tuned for
that particular task and yeah it worked
pretty well so this would be the the
fourier convolutions was it already in
the form that we see in the paper with
the two strands of information like the
global and the local or did you had to
shake things up uh no this uh this uh
the right part of this figure is uh
reflect the original uh form of this
phosphory convolution as it was proposed
by the authors cool and um did it work
out of the box yes but when we tuned
that for in painting we figured out that
the local branch is not really important
and we can handle almost everything with
just global branch with that spectral
transform
yeah
so but you still kept the local branch
in yeah because it helps for stability
especially in
not such large images and large masks
so
if we try to
push uh the generalization to high
resolution to extreme and to train on
very low resolutions and then infer in
very high
high resolutions uh then uh
using only global branch will pay more
but
in the real world
some combinations some combination of
these two is more practical
yeah so this is it's something i found
interesting because you have this point
of these large large masks or very wide
masks and so on and you stress the
importance of your algorithm that
produces these different masks now when
i look at these pictures
it doesn't seem that different right if
i look at the top row you know there's
also like some parts of the picture also
occluded relatively big parts there are
kind of some squiggles they're even
relatively wide right
why do you have an intuition
why
is the mask generation algorithm so
important is it is it important that
it's close to what humans do later or is
it important that it is of a certain
shape because of the architecture of the
network or what what's about what's the
deal with with that yeah as as with the
architecture we started with an existing
uh heuristic to
draw that masks and we actually we
follow the same algorithm as the use the
one used in deep field versus version
two uh
the first row in that figure
why why
masks should be wide yeah because
it is important because uh the width of
masks uh
forces the generator to pass the
information more far within itself
so if we we can cover uh almost all
input image with very thin uh lines for
example we can mask out every second row
and every second column in the input
image and that would be very something
very similar to a super resolution
problem
and the percent of the image will be
covered by such must but
the network
wouldn't need to pass information far
yeah that's that's why uh
white masks are important and they are
more more important for fully
convolutional architectures but for uh
fourier-based they are always
uh
help as well and we have
a couple of histograms in
our supplementary material which compare
actually the
first row of that figure with the mask
generated by our algorithm and the
difference is pretty huge actually it is
it is cool to see
that the difference is so big
i
think that
it was masked that it was point from
which we started actually because we
aimed to implement real world examples
and in that examples masks actually are
huge yeah so we started with big masks
on our validation set and we
saw that all
other algorithms of
fails to
fail to
feel
this flash calls
and then we started to think on how we
need to
change our model so that
it
can incorporate global information
yeah
is your is your algorithm deterministic
yeah if i give it the same input and the
same mask so if i and this is is this
correct the cleanup.pictures app that is
really your small model that runs here
now that this is the larger
model oh this is the big model already
okay so here you know i've i've
taken this but what happens have you
ever tried just masking the whole
picture
what's kind of like the default output
that's an interesting
i i
i don't know what will happen
i think
something average
a constant color maybe
let's see
yeah all right pretty unspectacular but
uh
i guess it's very gray is very high
probability right okay
yeah
cool um and then there's the the third
the third component is the loss and i
have to say the loss is a monstrosity
there are like 50 so first of all you
have no this this is the adversarial
part of the loss and then on top of that
you have like the uh
the uh discriminator perceptive loss i'm
gonna guess that's the same as the
perceptual loss but in the features of
the discriminators yeah yeah so the
features which are used to calculate uh
discriminatory-based perceptual loss are
updated throughout the trade throughout
training this is a pretty uh
commonly used
this is a commonly used loss in image to
image tasks
it helps to stabilize stabilize training
so you the idea is that the
discriminator bases its decisions on
features which are perceptually
meaningful
so very very similar to the perceptive
loss that you have
up here right
i think that uh
uh that feature matching or
discriminator based perception loss
helps mostly because it
uh provides a clear signal to the
generator and if in additional training
we have to balance a discriminator and
generator and if
oh one part is
more
powerful
the whole thing collapses and
discriminate based perception loss helps
to help the generator to catch up when
discriminator
becomes too
powerful yeah that makes sense um for
for all of these losses right and then
you have a regularizer on the gradients
and you have a this wide field
perceptive loss and so on is this
did you plan this from the beginning did
you say you know here is here are all
the good losses that i know of or did
you expect do you have more losses that
you ended up not including my question
is how if i'm a if i'm a researcher or
an engineer trying to come up with such
a system
how do i decide
which seven losses go into my final loss
right of the
50 possible losses that i could do do i
try them all or are there some some
guidelines
actually i think
all of these losses except for high
receptor field perceptual loss are
pretty common
and
they all
very often used in image damage tasks
like we need something to
force our
model to to create a realistic picture
so we need discrimination
and its laws
we need
to
reconstruct something that we can
reconstruct so we need some loss for
reconstruction
and added in the loss is too
restrictive so we need something that
works on features
but we
worked a lot on
we made a paper parameter search of
course
and we changed our
we work on our perceptual laws form
because we started with this
common perception was based on bgg model
but
we had a feeling that
it can be not perfect because it's
it was the model that
run on classification task
and
model
that
was retrained on classification
they
seems to concentrate on
gesture and not
global structure so
we decided to try something else
and then we find these models that
learned on segmentation tasks
and
on data set that is more similar to
uh ours that i said and we tried it and
could work
so the the segmentation task as a
training task for the perceptual loss
model is sort of a better preconditioner
than the classification task yeah yeah
because it is natural for the
segmentation model to focus more on
boundaries of objects instead of their
textures
and
in case of in painting
good texture can be
learned using only discriminator
because there is a lot of freedom in how
we can generate fine grained textures
and there is no need to put some any
supervision on that part
it's also
important that
models that are used for segmentation
are different
so
we compared in in our ablation uh we
compared uh
the same model that was
on the
uh
trend on classification and it works
well with the same model yeah you have
not only do you have a different task
with the segmentation you also include
also high receptive field layers into
that model so that the sensor the logic
is that if that model
also includes global information more
its its signal to your model will also
be more sensitive to that global
information it's a little bit like you
know in reinforcement learning people do
reward shaping it seems like you do
reward shaping by how you train the
different the different discriminator
models that that then give your model
the sort of the signal to learn yeah i
like the sort of the meta idea here
that's pretty cool
unfortunately i'm not familiar with uh
word shaping from reinforcement learning
but our idea here was that basically we
have two losses here the first one is
discriminator or the serial and which
focus more on fine-grained details and
the second
is perceptulos which focus more on
global text global structures
for the fourier convolutions maybe a
little bit more conceptual right we have
this local information in one strand we
have this global information in the
other strand and it's it's clear that
for these large masks as you show the
system works pretty well what kind of
data does your system work not well on
like what's what would be sort of the
worst input that i could give to your
system like this this up here is really
beautiful right well what picture could
i take such that it is absolute garbage
yeah actually lots of lots of images uh
will be
uh processed
bad with our model i mean a part of of
course i can give it a picture that is
you know very dissimilar to the training
data set but let's say i actually had a
training data set
what would be the worst domain on the
worst kind of picture
yeah um
it cannot
regret
half of human on something
yeah our model focuses mostly on
background due to how it was trained and
yeah it cannot uh recover
foreground objects really well it cannot
do something that requires it
to actually know everything about war
works and not just take it from picture
it sees
yeah so so is it is it
do you feel that the model mostly learns
how to sort of copy
elements from the part it sees to the
parts that are masked do you think that
the learning is mostly teaching the
model how to do that because it seems
the model is very sophisticated in you
know in photoshop you take this stamp
tool right you say i'll take a little
bit from over here put it here do you
think your model is just like a really
really good user of of that tool in a
sense yeah it seems
yes yes
and in order to be able to
uh create big parts of
images from scratch we need a different
kind of model and we
most probably need a kind of testity
within the generator because without it
it is not possible to create something
from nothing
yeah
oh also our model is quite small so
it cannot really remember
everything
yeah that is something that i left
completely out of my review i think the
fact that your model is compared to the
the baselines you compare to is a lot
smaller right it's it has way less
parameters
that is something that's i think very
cool and enables it to run inside web
applications and so on like on or maybe
on a mobile device or yeah i have i have
um another question and to the fourier
convolution so
here we have global information and and
local information right as as sort of
two different things you mentioned in
the paper that other models that have
more global information or access to
wider information could also work such
as a vision transformer or something
like this my question is is there an in
between between
local convolutions and fourier
convolutions okay i mean there's dilated
convolutions but if i think of a fourier
transform you transform into a space
where locality no longer matters but
frequency matters and in the original
domain frequency is just kind of doesn't
matter but locality really matters is
there a transform are there transforms
that we could do that put us in between
where
you know the as i go in the x-coordinate
it's a little bit of frequency and a
little bit of locality like is there
hope that instead of having multiple
columns of information we could sort of
choose our space wisely to trade off
local and global or do you think this is
already you know local like a mix with
two channels is a good way to go that's
that's a very good question
yeah and i don't know the answer to it
and
uh
one thing that comes to my mind is uh
there is a
short time for you transform which is
often used for music processing sound
processing and yeah it kind of combines
local convolutions with fourier
transform over it it is roughly can be
described as a processing the whole
signal with a sliding window and
transform each each
each sliding window with a
uh
with fourier transform yeah so
it is most obvious combination if you
had to give your intuition why the
fourier convolutions make such a big
difference here of course like the we've
already discussed fourier transform kind
of loses the locality of the signal and
gets global information but why fourier
transforms what what's kind of good
about this particular function that you
chose and space that you chose
surprisingly if we throw the local
branch away
it will still uh generate something
meaningful meaningful so
of spectral transform uh doesn't uh
loses uh that local uh
local local correlations uh completely
and i think that this is due to the fact
that uh the generator has uh spectral
transforms and uh spatial transforms
interleaving each other because here we
can see that
uh we have
cone one by one
between uh
between two fft and we have two more
convolutions before and after
uh the spectral transform they are
uh as well uh one by one so they
don't uh
capture local content directly but then
can combine uh channels on that
particular applications and yeah that
maybe that can uh somehow replace uh
traditional convolutions the fact that
this this uh spatial and spectral
transforms are interleaved
yeah
and when we think about generalization
to high resolution
i think uh
spectral transform
helps because of the fact that
low frequency part of spectrum
does not that's strong does not depend
on the resolution on the resolution that
strong
and uh it is almost the same
no matter if we have uh
uh
2056 or
sorry
256 or 2 000
yeah
yeah that by itself is one of the cool
properties again of your paper the fact
that it can scale up to sort of very
high resolutions there are artifacts
appearing but they are not nearly as
much as in other other models looks
pretty cool yeah it doesn't scale up uh
perfectly but yeah a bit better than uh
fully convolutional architectures cool
um yeah so where do you think i mean
maybe you don't want to disclose
necessarily but
what is the plan for the future
uh
we don't know where we
get uh
throughout research uh but uh
yeah the most obvious thing here is that
we can try to improve
uh the way generalized to higher
resolutions and the second point is
uh that we are trying to understand
uh why
actually it works that because it yeah
it has
lots of components
uh and we conducted an ablation study
regarding
uh if uh
validating if each of these components
matter but this is just a surface and we
can
go more in depth
in that
and we are not satisfied with our laws
because it's
that huge there are many components that
we need to
balance
and we want better loss with just one
to make two hyper parameters
just one button
make everything work and
no that's nice so yeah
i mean i i was almost i was expecting
you to say we're not happy with our loss
we want more we want like more
components to make but it is i think
it's pretty cool that uh the goal is
also to make a system that's kind of as
good but simpler um i think they'll make
it also much more accessible
cool yeah um
roman eliza sorry lisa
is that correct
yes okay lisa and roman thank you so
much for being here uh was it was a
pleasure do you have any last
criticisms to the video
or shout outs no thank you very much for
uh for the discussion it was really fun
and thank you for your channel because
it
you make a
real good job in helping others to be
in time and
to catch with
this huge wave of information that
we have in the field
thanks
yeah thank you thank you